today i'm going to be speaking with
professor catherine liu
who teaches at university of california
irvine
and is also author of the new book
virtue hoarders the case against the
professional managerial class
uh it's so great to have you on today
thank you david
so there's there's certainly a narrative
i think much of my audience will be
familiar with
um that is often used in some populist
circles about
elites and non-elites or an over class
and an
underclass and what one of the things
your book does that's interesting is
you're sort of focusing in on a specific
slice that's smaller than such a simple
division uh the managerial class
professional managerial class
let's start there what what is that
who's included in it etc
so um the professional manager class is
an intermediary class a lot of classic
marxists think um
call it the petite bourgeois because
it's located between the working class
which is the mass
of people without college degrees now
and
late capitalism in america and the
capitalists
so this class uniquely though in the
united states has become
really really important exports one of
the most important american
creations of the post-war period the
meritocracy
and it basically does the bidding of
capitalism and the capitalist by
producing
now we think of as content and
ideological content to justify
the really staggering levels of
inequality and exploitation
that keep late capitalism going so this
class are college educated
white-collar workers who i like to say
do jobs that don't entail physical
damage
to their bodies now they could actually
damage themselves psychologically and
intellectually which i think is actually
the case
but what they do is reproduce the
ideology of the class system
to make it seem like it's justified that
rich people are rich
and it's justified that the masses are
poor and that there
are no universal programs that would
actually create
a more equitable society now this is to
say though in 1977 when
john and barbara arreck wrote about this
class this class has taken over left and
progressive liberal
organizing spaces so it thinks of itself
as being
on the side of progress right and
virtuous and
good but actually its actions serve only
to
reproduce um the interests of capitalism
yeah this is it so i i think many in the
audience may
realize that that when you tell me is it
correct to call this a marxist
perspective
yes yeah uh as a non-marxist myself i
still think that the analysis
has a lot of very interesting things
that are that are accurate and you know
one of the things i was thinking of
during the 20 the rise of the tea party
in 2010
was that a lot of the people that were
supporting the tea party
they were definitely never going to
benefit from much of what the tea party
was advocating
for like it wasn't even there was a
chance they would benefit they
statistically
they just weren't going to benefit what
i think is interesting about the
managerial class that you're talking
about
is that they actually to some degree
could benefit from the propping up of
the actual over class that you describe
and so there's there actually seems to
be if you want to talk about rationality
it actually seems more rational to me
that they would prop that system up
whereas it made less sense with the tea
party people
but you know i think the tea party
people and populists about which i've
written in the past
are animated by a a rage
against the economic system that's left
them
marginalized but what they uh but what
they support were free markets
but also the val traditional values
and they hated the liberal elites right
the liberal elites have created
the um crisis in which they found
themselves and they're not
wrong right you know a lot of them were
not
um college educated people they were
small business people or
you know um we'd say like crap craftsmen
or you know there was like the classic
joe the plumber who turned out to be a
fake but
um there were these
um this population in america which i
would say
are non non-college-educated people
after world war
ii were really copiously rewarded by the
redistribution
of wealth that was put into place by
both republican
and democratic administrations after
1945
but since 1972 as you know the middle
and the working classes have seen their
wages
stagnate actually go down we've seen the
social safety net
be destroyed and so a lot of the
actual um economic damage that people
suffered from in the tea party um
setting
and i would say also when trump
supporters had to do with
the imposition of this kind of
neoliberal austerity politics and
actually free markets that were
engineered by economists academics
and elites after 1972 of both parties
right
so what they wanted in the tea party was
less government because they thought the
government had created
you know the financial crisis and
the government didn't did
participate in creating the financial
crisis but it was
wall street and financiers as you know
who really um
produced this crisis in capital
destroyed a trillion dollars in american
assets like overnight
and um there was this fantasy that they
that the tea party had that it was
people borrowing on that with bad credit
who overspent and who
and they were to blame and somehow the
government the bank and you know some
banks
participated in that i heard this line
repeated to me
by a very wealthy liberal who said you
know what caused this crisis
all those people couldn't afford the
houses and
everyone wants a flat screen tv so in
fact
she is actually being more rational
although wrong because it was actually
goldman sachs morgan stanley and aig
that created the crisis
the credit default swap created the
crisis but there's this idea
there are these poor people over
consuming
who um had bad credit and they brought
the
world economy to its knees and so the
tea party had that idea and they were
like all mad at fox news
but also msnbc cnn watching
elite liberals had that same idea so
there's actually this consensus about
how poor people
caused um the financial crisis that tea
partiers
and liberal elites shared pmc liberally
chaired yeah i don't i don't know if
this is um
i don't know if this this is analog or a
part of or or
parallel to your analysis but to some
degree what i'm hearing you say about
the tea party and and then also some on
the left is
similar to i use the term bamboozling
but there's probably a different term
that could be used that
the populist rhetoric has succeeded with
over the last
many years where it pulls in people from
both
left and right with what are typically
different voting patterns
and stated uh values that that would
differ
but the rhetoric starts to sound similar
on the left and right but then the
solutions
don't match up when you actually ask
people well how would you solve this
problem
but there's a similar level of
irrationality and what i think is really
insane is that the professional
managerial classes
have always prided themselves on being
rational right reasonable they're
located in the university they all went
to fancy universities
and have credentials but they are
utterly irrational right now
and i think that the um russia gate
thing
is a really good example of their
rationality like what happened to that
but nobody's supposed to not trust msnbc
after they made that whole kerfuffle
about something that didn't really
they had no proof for so that's
something that's in the book too is how
i show the pmc
elites now do not abide by the high
liberal values of either due process
or reason rationed our rational argument
in the public sphere
and you know certainly on the right
people do not believe in reason
and rational argument in the public
sphere either so our the state of our
politics today has
a you know it finds ourselves in this
position where nobody wants to defend
argumented
argument reasonable um people debating
each other
not um agreeing with each other and the
pmc
liberals like to blame this on fox news
and blame this on extreme
right forces but they are policing their
own boundaries
in the same exact way and they're
demonizing their antagonists
to make them seem like they really don't
deserve to even exist or
vote when they and then they say the
republicans want to suppress the vote
but i think that there's a lot of
contempt for
non-college educated americans not
working class americans
that's actually in the pmc itself yeah
i'm under i
the part that is less clear to me is the
the russiagate piece because
you know i to it seems to me that
certainly there were some people who
very early on
were setting expectations that were
unreasonable like you know trump's going
to be caught on video
planning something with putin you know
that was never going to happen trump's
going to end up in prison
that was never going to happen you know
you go back to my videos from april of
2017 and that's what i said all along
but in in great part i don't see
maybe msnbc was doing different things
than i saw i don't really watch any of
any msnbc or that type of stuff but
from the perspective of um
that this led to not only uh
more than a dozen indictments but it
actually found enough wrongdoing to
recover more money than the
investigation cost
uh it is very clear that donald trump
was a useful idiot in a number of
different ways and part of it did
overlap with
i don't know that i see that as the same
thing that you
see it as necessarily okay well
i you know that is a very reasonable
take and i totally appreciate that
um what i think was what i was talking
about more
i guess is the energy of condemnation
that they were sure was going to lead to
an impeachment
i see and it works only partially
but it's so different i was alive during
you're probably too young to remember
watergate
when there was bipartisan condemnation
of nixon
when the work was done to bring in the
republicans and say something so
bad has happened yeah something so
illegal has happened
that we have to condemn this person and
the russiagate thing
did find wrongdoing but it didn't
actually create because
you know our politics are so polarized
now a national consensus
but i think that's an indictment of the
republican party
i think because when i see there was a
point in watergate where
where the reason there was not
impeachment was because
it became clear that nixon was going
down
if it went that far because republicans
i i think that the reason it went the
way it did
is an indictment on republicans no i
absolutely agree
but i also think there's the core and
irrational poor if you like
of republican support um popular support
for trump or right-wing popular support
for trump
that is animated by hatred of the
professional managerial class
and the more you like um have these
liberal talking heads you know pumping
people up about
cultural issues ignoring actual bread
and butter economic issues or
suffering yeah the majority of americans
the more you will have this
label of hypocrisy being thrown at
liberal elites
and this idea also that there are worthy
people to help and
unworthy people to help that is usually
a republican
and right-wing talking point but the
liberal elite pmc
has actually done this completely like
there are good poor people and there are
bad working-class people
and we're going to give all of the moral
iniquity
to the other side well and not and they
do not see their complicity
in actually bringing us to a state where
the country is so polarized and so
divided
and animated by these class antagonisms
and hatreds
that should be talked about rationally
they can't do that though because that
would mean that they were not
um saintly in some way i think the pmc
has like tried to cloak itself
in a kind of stately identity that
always has to put itself on the right
side of things
let's look at the state of california we
have an incredible homeless problem
that is in large part generated by
regulations on housing and
land use in the state the pmc here in
the state though they rule right the
democratic
elites have super majorities and
everything in every legislative branch
in this
state and yet they can only
put up black lives matters signs in
their yards
and they refuse to have lower income
housing built in their neighborhoods
or homeless shelters built in their
neighborhoods or even
create higher density housing so that
we're not living in suburban enclave
suburban um hell right this
this um this state
with its veneer of liberalism and its
preachiness about tolerance
has actually created this kind of
dystopia
of inequality that they don't really
actually want to solve
the um look at the san francisco school
board they stopped this now
but rather than asking for funding to
get schools open in the correct way
supporting teachers
and students they wanted to rename
san francisco public schools 44 of them
one of them named after abraham lincoln
because of the racism of the past right
that just
infuriates me so much because first of
all
like i i don't like dianne feinstein i
don't think she should have a school
name but after her
but if you just go after these cosmetic
things and then you say like people who
are
from the past like lincoln were racist
what the pmc
there is saying is you know everyone who
came before us
are racist we're um enlightened and
we're going to create a cosmetic
um superficial veneer of tolerance and
anti-racism
ignoring all of the structural economic
inequalities that has made the san
francisco school system
majority minority right african-american
latinos
and asian-american working-class people
use that public school system
the um wealthy elites of all um they're
mostly white but miss some of them asian
some of them african-americans some of
them are
latino they send their kids to private
schools and this is what has happened in
every city in the country is this kind
of
live service to public education and
this
undermining of public goods so that the
upper tier of the pmc can enjoy
privatized education and everyone else
is left with
poor quality mass education that
nevertheless has a veneer of
um tolerance and that's like a great pmc
strategy for
virtue hoarding and um reproducing
economic inequality
so in the very limited time we have left
i want to get your thoughts on
how we've talked about this issue of the
the cultural fights
that you know particularly in the trump
era the right
is not they're not even pretending to be
about policy anymore it's it's you know
dr
seuss it's cancelled culture it's et
cetera et cetera
as a strategic uh calculation
should the left fight these cultural
issues or should they just
ignore them and focus on policy or
something else well the left doesn't
have
doesn't have much of a commitment to
freedom of speech right now so i think
if the left
fights these issues i'm not sure what
they're going to actually be standing on
because they
actually don't want dr seuss books to be
reproduced those books are really
problematic in many ways but
also a lot of people enjoyed those books
i enjoyed those books for my kids
and my kid and so i i feel like the
culture
war aspect of um
american politics serves elites on both
sides of the party
so it doesn't i guess the reason i think
it serves the right more
is that the left has a package right now
when it comes to
infrastructure foreign policy taxation
pandemic that's absent from a lot of the
the new right so it strikes me that it
would be better for the left to focus on
that
um their policies i i'm always someone
who's for
focusing on economic material issues
okay
that is the bottom line what is who
benefits who doesn't benefit
remain focused on the economics that's
um i think always going to work much
better and actually deliver for people
not just focus on economic policies that
will create more redistribution
redistribution of wealth but really
deliver i think the vaccine
is a sign that there can be like
publicly funded health initiatives yeah
and that
you should focus on that you should hope
we should focus on creating
um strong infrastructure within public
health universal health care
universal quality child care all of
these bread and butter issues that
people need in their lives desperately
right
now and if you can produce that then you
can produce a sense of the collective
you can produce a sense of progressive
liberal policies that work for people
yes and so in that sense
they should not take the bait the left
should not take debate on the cultural
issues they should absolutely deflect
and i and you know i've had my i've been
agnostic on biden but i do feel like
he's much more progressive than obama
and that his um stimulus packages be
something that is
executed with the greatest fervor and
authority and here's
here's one thing i'm going to um um end
with is that
i'm not playing the pm the pmc blame
game where i say oh
the pmc they're all bad no we need good
professionals
we can't have infrastructural
reconstruction of this country
without return to the professional
standards
of both like stock broking or you know
researching universities or um policy
making and think tanks
that is shielded from the market right
now all of these knowledge workers are
so
driven by profit and we need to go back
to
non-market professional standards of
being
and that's i think something that we
often lose track of in the left and
we think like oh um anybody who's a
bureaucrat is bad
how are you going to spend 1.9 trillion
dollars
correctly or well without a good
functioning bureaucracy without a good
functioning government
that's why i have no patience for the
anarcho
leftists yes you and me both you and me
both uh the book is virtue hoarders
the case against the professional
managerial class we've been speaking
of course with the book's author
professor catherine liu so great to have
you on today
thank you david thank you so much